so someone has a negative problem how do
we how do we fix that put him in charge
we have someone that needs to get humble
that needs to learn some humility how do
you do that
put them in charge that's what you do
you put them in charge of something that
they can't
barely handle and what's interesting is
sometimes you get feedback like
wouldn't it be better like let's say
dave has a big ego
and wouldn't it be better just to have a
straightforward kind of robust
conversation
with dave and say listen dave i think
your ego's a little out of control
and i think you need to humble yourself
are there instances where that may work
there are if dave
in addition to having a big ego looks at
me as a
as a person that he can learn a lot from
and he has a ton of respect for me
and that and we have a good relationship
and i can approach it in a in a way
that's indirect enough that
it doesn't offend him and i can sit him
down and and sometimes
you can be direct with someone some of
you got a great relationship with
someone if you and i have a great
relationship
and i go hey man you're letting your ego
get the best of you if i think you're
trying to help me i'm going to listen to
you yup
yup so so there are times that that can
work
here's the problem there are more times
where the reason that the person the
reason that we have a problem is because
the person has a big ego in the first
place that's the whole reason why we
have the problem
so when we just point blank tell them
well we're attacking their ego they're
going to dig in it's going to get even
worse
okay so there's one example what about
when we got someone that lacks
confidence
and wouldn't it be good if we could just
tell them hey look dave have more
confidence
guess what the reason the person doesn't
have confidence because they don't have
confidence
just telling someone to have more
confidence is zero effect
okay maybe it has five percent effect
maybe it has an eight percent effect
but when i say hey dave you know what
you lack confidence
so i want you to have more confidence
that's not what we're talking about when
instead i say
hey dave you know what i've been
watching you and and i'm seeing what
you're doing
and it seems to me like you've got some
potential here for real leadership
and what i want to do is i want to
assign a couple things to you here in
fact we've got this project that we're
working on
and i want you to actually take charge
of this and then dave who lacks
confidence says oh boss i'm not really
ready for this i go hey look
let me let me just show you what the
project consists of it's this and this
it's pr it's pretty straightforward i
know you've actually already done this
you just haven't been the person with
the name on it
look at it look at the look at what the
oh yeah yeah you see you can do this
cool this is a great place for you to
start let's knock this thing out of the
park
and all of a sudden dave does it and his
confidence goes up a little bit
right it's real it's real
so the idea that we can
just use words look it's it absolutely
hey can i have a conversation with dave
and say hey dave you know what
right now you might not feel like you're
ready but you're ready can that boost
his confidence yes it can i'm not saying
that it can't
it can can i possibly say hey dave your
ego is out of control and you need
you need to start being a little bit
more humble and that can work yes it can
work
but for the reasons i just gave there's
a there's
the the more powerful tool
is using leadership using leadership to
teach people
so got a whole section in here
on that building or rebuilding
confidence
and by the way you don't necessarily
need to be correcting a problem
to use leadership as a as a instruction
tool you don't need that
you don't you don't need it at all you
can you can actually
uh use leadership to teach and build
just for your team just to make them
better
like you don't need to have a problem i
don't need to go to dave and think oh
dave's got a big ego or
lacks confidence or a bad attitude to
say now i'm going to put him in charge
no no i want to have a
an awesome team so what i'm going to do
is put people in charge i'm going to use
leadership to build an awesome team
these are things that
counterintuitive answer to a lot of
people i i mean when somebody asked me
hey i got a person with a bad attitude
and i say put him in charge right
someone says hey i got a person with a
big eagle and i said put him in charge
someone says hey i've got a person that
that lacks confidence and i say put him
in charge
counterintuitive every time that's but
it is
absolutely the best tool yeah to educate
the the difference is is the leader that
actually really cares that truly cares
about his people
is not i'm not doing that i'm not gonna
put jacqueline church so i can crush his
ego i'm still
actually doing it to try to help him out
that's the difference there
as opposed to watch this bro and then i
just
roll in on jocko with the big ego
because what i really want to do
is crush him and assert my authority of
him the leader that actually cares about
his people that really wants the team to
be successful
we'll look and then go okay this guy's
got a problem it's a totally
understandable problem that most people
have
i'm going to use this as a tool to help
him be successful
i would like his ego to be put in check
as a result but i still what i really
want is for him to grow and develop and
i'm using the best way to do it
the common denominator amongst the guy
that's just growing and evolving and
needs more
responsibility and the dude that is out
of his head and over
you know way huge ego that needs is that
i still care about both of them
and so as a leader if you're listening
to this this isn't a punitive tool
to destroy your people whose egos are
out of control it's a
tool to help crush the biggest hindrance
this person have
to being individually successful and
contribute to your team
but as a leader you need to care about
that person and really want him to be
successful knowing
that the best tool to do that for him is
all right bro
you got a big ego hey let's put you in
charge of this
you're doing a lot of subtle things and
runs but if your whole thing is oh giaco
told me to just pile on this guy until i
break him that's not what what this is
about yeah and by the way it doesn't
start off
hey you got a big eagle i'm gonna put
you in charge of this it starts off with
hey dave
yeah man you've been you've been kind of
dominating and and you know what
i think i think you can start stepping
up and i got some stuff here that i
think's gonna be easy pie for you
here here's the next project and dave
grabs and goes i got this
yeah but as you know again this is all
explained in detail to the books of
how much what what level of project are
you going to give
we want it to be enough that we're not
crushing them with that project yeah
right
totally and just for me it's eager to
get wrapped around easy to get wrapped
around
the idea of of fixing this person's
problem
but what a good leader really does is
looks at all its people even the ones
that are doing
all the things that that frustrates you
is hey i really need help it's the same
thing with my kids
i got my kids doing things that drive me
nuts that i want to crush
but i'm actually doing it because i want
them to be successful over time
not because i just want to prove the
point of overwhelming them with
responsibility to their to their
breaking point
you have to know that what you're
actually trying to do is make this
person get better
and you use this word hindrance which
is it's so important to understand
that the problem that you're trying to
fix
the ego is the hindrance to why
the direct conversation isn't as
effective
as real world experience
same thing with someone that lacks
confidence
that the the the problem is the
hindrance
when i lack confidence me being told
that my confidence that i that i should
have more isn't
enough to propel me past it just like
when someone tells me i need to be more
humble that's not compelling enough for
me to actually get humble because i
already think i'm awesome
and when i lack confidence i i don't
think i'm good enough so what we need is
to actually
reinforce with compelling methods
how to improve people uh in this
paradigm
of of problems that they have yeah
and that's why the direct approach
almost never works
yeah yeah the amount
of people the amount of relationships
that are so
strong that this sort of hey
just gonna hit you with the direct
feedback
is you know a tiny percentage tiny
percentage of relationships
yeah and if your relationship actually
is that strong
that problem that you're dealing with
would never get to an out of control
state anyway so
if you're contemplating the direct
approach it's such a narrow narrow
narrow
times to use that yeah